"The latest in school segregation"
was how the headline of a recent New York Times op-ed described private "pandemic pods,"
in which parents get together and hire an in-person teacher
while public schools remain remote.
The pandemic pods, says the writer,
"will exacerbate inequities, racial segregation and the opportunity gap within schools."
Business Insider had a slightly different take,
they said the pods were "inequitable and inevitable"
and that the arrangements were "a dream come true for the school choice movement."
But are pandemic pods just the latest tool through which white parents use their financial and political clout
to separate out their kids, thus increasing educational segregation?
And is the solution to increase government spending in K-12 schools
so that all parents will want to keep their kids in the public system?
That was the subject of an online Soho Forum debate held on Wednesday, September 16th, 2020.
Arguing for more government spending was Jon Hale,
a professor of education at the University of Illinois, Urbana-Champaign.
Arguing in favor of pods and other parental innovations was Corey DeAngelis,
the director of school choice at the Reason Foundation,
which publishes ReasonTV.
Here's Jon Hale and Corey DeAngelis in an online debate moderated by the Soho Forum's Director Gene Epstein.